what's the mission called we're going to
build a colony on the moon first and
then from the moon we launch to go to
mars
project artemis yeah artemis there you
go well you want to know why it's never
going to happen
ian what going to mars yeah i'm going to
blame the media do it check out this
check out the story
new npr ethics policy it's okay for
journalists to demonstrate
sometimes you know why i think i'm
willing to bet they changed that
headline
they say npr rolled out a substantial
update to its ethics policies earlier
this month
expressly stating that journalists may
participate in activities that advocate
for the freedom and dignity of human
beings
on both social media and real life the
new the new policy eliminates the
blanket prohibition from participating
in marches rallies and public events
as well as vague language that directed
npr journalists to avoid personally
advocating for controversial or
polarizing issues
this policy will change the moment an
npr employee comes out with a gadsden
flag preaching to end the lockdowns
they're going to be like not that
freedom and dignity that's
fascism that's the thing i think every
every activist thinks that they're
involved in the pursuit of freedom and
dignity i think npr really hasn't
thought this one through
because the you know the first even like
and
even a pro-cuban activist i can't see
npr being okay with that that's a good
point
yeah well they say that the new policy
reads npr editorial staff may express
support for democratic civic values
that are core to npr's work such as but
not limited to
the freedom and dignity of human beings
the rights of a free and independent
press
the right to thrive in society without
facing discrimination on the basis of
race ethnicity gender
sexual identity disability or religion
what was the first one
the first one was the rights of uh i'm
sorry
the freedom and dignity of human beings
including unborn human beings
oh no of course the rights of free and
independent press
so you can protest in support of
infowars oh yeah alex jones
yeah yeah is it okay to march in a
demonstration and say black lives matter
what about a pride parade in theory the
answer today is yes but in practice
npr journalists will have to discuss
specific decisions with their bosses
who in turn will have to ask a lot of
questions the carved is somewhat narrow
protests organized with the purpose of
demanding equal and fair treatment of
people are now permitted
as long as the journalist asking is not
covering that event however rallies
organized to support a specific piece of
legislation would be off-limits
other events featuring a slate of
political candidates from one party are
also out of bounds
from one party are we saying that there
were no npr reporters at like
the pink hat march in 2016 like come
on yeah lots of them actually in fact
i know a lot of npr people are activists
like they're they're all activists new
york the whole media apparatus in new
york new york's a different country at
this point
i don't even know what's going on in new
york their the media ecosystem in new
york is
insane yeah you're you're on an island
yeah new york post you guys are yeah
they censor you they block your stories
yes and then
like it's it's really cabally that
you're familiar with the journal
lists of course so for those that aren't
familiar
new york journalists had this and they
probably still do lists of where
uh message boards basically where they
all communicate and share stories and
all believe the same things
and it's basically like there's no
competition in media
because all the news outlets are in the
same place right even fox news but the
joke with journalists is like they were
sharing opinions and like people
were like journalists have opinions like
come on like why don't we just be honest
about it like why doesn't everybody just
speak their bias and like get it over
with we all know
that everybody's biased like it's
there's no such thing as somebody who
like
has no predisposed opinions like just
get it out there
yeah but maybe this whole thing is over
with like you know yes
like journalism being no opinions to be
a public figure
and your goal is just to report but then
to use that position to assert
that's where the problem arises if
you're just trying to be a journalist
and i i think you're right maybe it's
just over
it's over about it yeah it's it's it's
propagandistic warfare at this point
right that's it yeah i mean i saw um
somebody yesterday i shared a tweet and
they were quoting nbc news but because
the guy i shared it from
um it was robbie's darpa starbucks yeah
so somebody was like
i can't take you seriously when you
share robbie starbuck but he was like
literally
just quoting nbc news he had clipped the
article but it was like no
i can't i cannot even cannot use his
copy and paste i cannot have his uh
you know fingerprints on this and it's
just
it's so tribal that we like can't even
believe a news source when somebody we
don't like shares it
yeah we're at a point where the hyper
polarization is so
intense i don't think the news is
relevant anymore people will scan the
news and be like
don't care if that's true don't care if
that's true this one kind of screws me
if it's true so i'll ignore it and this
one
perfect let me tweet that yeah that's it
and then i don't know where we end up my
my thing is get out of the cities you
know
don't sit around they're taking they're
they're ticking time bombs
they're going to lock down everything
again miami's doing well yeah that's
true a really good mayor
yep yeah miami is doing well florida in
general texas so maybe
maybe it's um if you live in a blue
state stay there
there you go you know don't come out
here npr's private company
yeah they call it public radio but it's
funded by private money
two percent of their revenue comes from
uh public grants from i think the
department of commerce and the
department of education we actually
pulled this up before the show
a lot of people keep saying it's my tax
dollar it's like a little bit i guess
but you know sure it is your tax dollars
to a certain degree yeah npr is uh uh
you know a lefty progressive media
outlet i
jimmy dore was telling joe rogan about
this when he was on a show and i was
thinking
yeah joe actually said well they should
have to change their name
yeah i was just about to say that it's
not public radio right and like the
federal express
had to change it it's not federal the
federal reserve is not federal
they had to change it to fedex yeah i
don't know if they had to but they did
in like the 90s it used to be called
federal express
it still is federal express it's fedex
now according to
yeah they officially changed it yeah i
think it's i think that is that you
could call it public or federal
right it is not federal expert wow i
didn't know that yeah
i don't know if they did to avoid a
lawsuit or what but i'm glad they did
yeah even the word fed is a little
misleading yeah
why did they change their name i want to
feed this
i want to i'm going to say somebody told
me that every time a company changed
their name like
dairy queen changed her name to dq and
kfc yeah kfc
right there's a reason they do it
there's always a reason the kentucky
fried chicken they they didn't actually
have enough chicken right oh really i
thought it was because fried chicken
like you know it was like health
consciousness had like
increased yeah i'm not sure about that
fried chicken was out maybe that's more
i don't think they were forced to change
their name from federal i don't think
that i don't remember it ever being
forced
i just said it happened like in the 90s
or something fact-checked yeah it was
2 000 they rebranded everything to
federal to fedex
and all the planes and everything was
changed yeah maybe it was i don't know
i would like to see that put into law
that you can't call your company federal
or
because i was like could i make a
company called like federal national
broadcast corporation and like sell
t-shirts you can't
i don't know if i can is that legal it
shouldn't be legal didn't the postal
service sue
the band the postal service oh i don't
know oh yeah that's
yeah that's ridiculous because they're
they're entities who have branding and
names and stuff like that
that may have happened i'm not sure the
postal service is a big deal they
thought
ben franklin was like the first
postmaster general and that was a
national
company now we have ups we have
basically amazon is like our our
national shipping agency right now and
it's a corporation like we
really need a national a national
shipping
like organization i don't know about the
post office
yeah yeah but we need more of those but
i don't like the government having
monopoly on that stuff either can we go
to the market
go to mars already can we just can can
joe biden come out and be like
i'm gonna scrap everything in the budget
bill and we're just going to spend it on
mars
i'd be like all right there we go i'm
down let's print that money i'm i'm
bored somebody slips that idea to him
right before he goes on and you have a
good shot of it
you know what can we sneak index cards
to biden yeah you know so it's like he's
handed the cards
like we do this ocean's 11 style thing
where the cards get switched and then
he's like
we're gonna go go to mars
yeah that's it i'm done yeah good you
could probably pull it off
i'd be like i don't care about the
culture or stuff you would do it they're
saying the same thing yesterday they're
saying today it's just getting noisier
and noisier and more confusing and let's
just go to mars
that's just we'll just go let's do it
you know we'll send we'll send a bunch
of supplies first do we know what goals
is that is that the best option right
now
no they're magnetic mars doesn't have
the mass to sustain life in any
meaningful way
unless we build like bases and the issue
is that we'd have to build a massive we
have we have we'd have to be able to
build and
we'd be able to refine fuels and build
rockets to get off the planet in the
first place so it's like mostly a
one-way trip but then
you'd have to live in in bunkers forever
because of radiation and because of
there's no atmosphere and there's no
magnetosphere to protect from the
maybe we should consider this whole yeah
like let's do some other stuff first
all right all right here's my other day
let's find an earth-like exoplanet yes
and just go for it yeah all right that's
it i mean that sounds better than you're
you know living yeah it's gonna take
it'll take too long
can we build a stargate or something
yeah can we find one probably
a good show sure yeah i think you could
super accelerate through
um black holes through those what are
they called charged black holes
they have a double event horizon i think
you can super accelerate through them to
another star
you want to know the sad reality if
there is life out there that travels the
stars
and they have massive ships that can
travel faster than light and all that
stuff
we are about humble chickens on the
earth they look at us
like like nothing you know not even i'm
thinking about like when i watch the
chickens go do their chicken business
and they're like walking around making
little weird noises and they went into
our garden bed where we have the basil
and they started digging because they
like to do these dirt baths and they
uprooted the basil and i'm like so we
got to re-pot them but you look at them
doing that and we laugh like look at
them they're so dumb they're rolling
around in dirt and then i'm imagining
like i'm sitting here like
working on the computer and like reading
up stories and imagining like some
interstellar ultra intelligent species
being like look at them they're like
trying to read information but they go
so slow they can barely understand
what's going on in their own world eyes
did you see the the meme that was like
what if ufos are just other
uh planet brilliant planets millionaires
they probably are
yeah they probably wouldn't i mean it's
not going to be the
the well i don't know it's assuming
there's wealth and that kind of stuff on
other planets
yeah you know we we have we can barely
leave our own planet
yeah it's like we go to the moon 70
whatever you're 60 something years ago
and we're like yay we
we went from the blue one to the little
one and that's as far as we've gone but
i mean nobody else has gone there's only
one flag on the moon
i mean at least we're still number one
you know it's true yeah for now
like we're not that great compared to
ben but we're still better than
everybody else
yeah we need to i don't know we need
like how do we how do we have that big
scientific breakthrough
yeah you know rocketry was amazing how
do we get that anti-grav man how do we
get that uh uh
you know faster than light travel oh
maybe it's not possible maybe we're
trapped here
it's possible we need to mathematically
prove it first that's why einstein's
equals mc square was so revolutionary
because he he simplified the mathematics
that showed the i don't know what what
is that the speed of light
equals energy energy equals the mass
times velocity
yeah the mass squared times the speed of
light um
and he basically i don't know created
like a density of energy or something
um but he made it he did it simply so if
we can
show that you can get more energy out of
a system than you put into it like for
150 years they've been
quoting these these ancient laws like
newton laws that are like say you can't
get more energy out of a system than you
put in
see that's how how you get water out of
wells and they're like using these old
theories
but if we can rewrite physics
mathematically then people
will accept it then the technology will
start to become exciting you know you
know
you know be cool as we say i don't think
we're around for any of that but
yeah what if like one day some dude's
just chilling
and then he accidentally like sneezes
and farts at the same time and it pulls
up the console commands
and then he's like he sees this like you
know you know the what
what is that little thing called the
indicator when it's blinking on the
screen whatever and then he's like
uh and then uh appears and he's like
search
item list one through 100 and then i'll
send a bunch of words
and then it just starts like
manipulating you know you know console
commands all right video games
yeah yeah like when you play like
follow-up forward slash forward slash
c you could do like you know character
health
one million and then he's just like whoa
and then
he's like set player size one thousand
he's like he's like
and then all of a sudden we see some
dude just destroying reality with
console commands
i'd actually welcome that i'd be like
hey at least something's happening i
guess
you know because other than that it's
just same old thing every single day
with the insanity and the absurdity and
no one does anything
like we get the republicans being like
we refuse to wear masks and i'm like oh
we did this last year
yeah like here we go again it's crazy
that this is like we have the internet
and it's so amazing and
like we should be so wowed by it every
day and we use it to argue with like
doofuses
on twitter at least i do for sure i
restrained myself
so hard such a time so i'm gonna try
even to you and chris i can't i can't
bring myself to talk to you guys on
twitter
i just came oh you saw that tweet yeah
it was just text we were talking about
censorship ian thinks that piracy isn't
theft
and my brother got mad because he made
uh a video
that went viral and was pirated over a
billion times
literally a billion times and his face
isn't in the video
so when it got pirated he got no credit
for it and in fact it took the money
away from
his actual revenue source which was the
video on his youtube channel
and that then he started trying to go
after people like who are stealing it
they're putting in tv shows or whatever
a billion views it's crazy that's a lot
of money yeah and he got
zero for it because it was stolen and
the funny thing is the video is like
years and years old
you may have seen it it is a van and
then it says
actual police footage and a hand reaches
out it's being pulled over by a cop you
know you hear the police chatter
and then there's a baggie attached to
balloons and he releases the balloons
and it says how to ditch your stash
and then the cop runs out so it's firing
it here so it's really fake
but because his face isn't in the video
he gets no credit for it
what do you do watermark videos and
stuff it's impossible
so if you the assumption that you had
ian was that someone's going to earn
recognition because it's a picture of
their face
and their name but a lot of people
produce music with no words
so there's no singing it's just a song
like i oh and then they just download it
and then they don't know who made it or
where it came from and it goes viral and
then
the people who made it really good
example who is that guy
um rusty cage he has that the the knife
song
um he he he did a video where he took a
knife and he was doing the knife game
with your fingers
and he sang he's like i forgot how the
song goes
and then what happened was some rapper
used that line
and then on tic tac the song went crazy
viral
with for someone else who had basically
taken what he had written on tick-tock
yeah it went viral because uh someone
took the song and then remade it
the melody and everything but put it in
their own song and then he didn't get
any credit for it it was just basically
taken from him
and then the other guy gets to go viral
for it so yeah that's the problem of
i mean i guess that's just general
copyright infringement yeah but the
piracy was people taking my brother's
videos and then re-uploading it all
across their own channels and just
publishing it and sharing it whenever
they want with it
yeah i don't like when people um what do
you call it impersonate
like take credit for your work i don't
like that that's bad actually very bad
but what about if you write a song and
then everyone starts downloading it and
they don't know who wrote it or where it
came from that's a problem
yeah that's the problem with you got to
be able to help someone trying to run it
yeah so the funny thing is the reason
chris got mad about that is
he dedicated a lot of time and energy he
got a car they got props they bought all
this stuff they produced it
he got nothing for it and now he and
then he was eventually like we i can't
afford to do this anymore mm-hmm
we should play the video someday we do
credit
we spent money to make this video we it
was taken like the success of the video
was robbed from us
and we just generally lost money so now
there's no more videos
otherwise that could have been way more
rectify thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus
episodes thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time
you